que quería hacer cuando eras pequeño yo
quiere ser un astronauta probablemente
algunos quisieron ser seres de su propio
restaurante escritores cantantes
estrellas de rock cuando somos jóvenes
tenemos muchísimos sueños y ambiciones y
genuinamente queremos que los podemos
lograr porque para un niño de 10 años
todo es posible pero qué está pasando
pero que un niño entra en la escuela
queriendo ser astronauta y salga
queriendo ser contador porque tiene más
salidas porque pagan mejor porque ahí
tengo que ser realista y dónde quedaron
todos esos sueños y aspiraciones a los
que tú querías pero no tienen la
etiqueta de que son mejores para tu
futuro cuando yo tenía 7 años comenzó a
estudiar robótica ya los días me topé
una persona con discapacidad motriz en
un supermercado y al ver que ni siquiera
podía agarrar la manzana que tenía
enfrente yo me quedé en shock algo que
para mí es completamente sencillo para
esa persona era prácticamente imposible
ese día yo me hizo una promesa personal
conlleva un día iba a crear algo para
que esa persona pueda regresar a ser
autónoma que pueda ser independiente
y no sabía ni que ni como hasta los 16
años donde decidí comenzar me buscar al
respecto busqué sobre discapacidades
cuánta gente las tenía y qué
dificultades habían ahí encontré que
para la discapacidad motriz hay
muchísimas cosas y todos los días van
mejorando porque hay de todas las demás
discapacidades hay encontré que cada
cinco segundos a limpiar de la vista y
mientras otras industrias han
evolucionado muchísimo como la de los
celulares o la de los carros el bastón
para personas ciegas se ha quedado
exactamente igual les explico
este es un hace casi 100 años
y este es un carro de hoy muchísima
diferencia no ahora este es un bastón
blanco para personas con discapacidad
visual de 1921
el primero crecimiento y este
es un bastón blanco para personas con
discapacidad visual del 2018
como pueden ver en casi 100 años no ha
cambiado absolutamente nada y en un
mundo tan caliente como el nuestro
esta herramienta dejó de ser precisa se
convierte en una herramienta es
actualizada y con muchísimas limitantes
cuando yo me di cuenta de todo esto
sabía que es ahí donde tiene que hacer
algo
fue ahí cuando comencé a adjuntar mis
conocimientos de electrónica de
programación para crear algo después de
analizar el bastón sabía que yo tenía
que crear algo que te dejarán las manos
libres que no gastas energía al estarlo
usando golpeando personas como el
mobiliario
tiene que ser algo que sea difícil de
perder y ser algo que tenga muchísima
seguridad para la persona ciega tanto en
cuestión de autoestima como en cuestión
de saber qué hay en su entorno después
de algunos de ese trabajo salió algo
parecido a esto salió un prototipo muy
feo sería un prototipo que se ve
bastante incómodo y freak o empapado
súper emocionado papá papá mira lo que
hice y era bastante normal que yo
llegara a mi casa con un nuevo invento
que supuestamente iba a cambiar el mundo
pero esta vez mi papá contestó que
dejara de al inventor que me
pusiera a estudiar porque mira mal en la
escuela en este momento en tener un
pequeño elemento de trabajar hacer mi
tarea o continuar haciendo eso que tanto
me gustaba claramente la otec lo ganó
muy sencillamente continuar haciendo
esto que yo estaba haciendo y no hay que
hacer ningún experto para saber que eso
está muy feo es bastante incómodo y les
adelanto que muy apenas funcionaba
decide empezar de cero y después de
algunos días de trabajo se le un nuevo
prototipo esta vez
más bonito y un poco más funcional solo
algo como esto
esta vez jalaba muy bien y fui con mi
papá elige papá mira lo que hice
ojalá mejor está más bonito qué opinás
base para los ciegos les va avisar
cuando cuando van a chocar esta vez mi
papá ya muy frustrado decidió decirme lo
siguiente el día en que yo vi a una
persona siga que se lo ponga y me diga
que es la maravilla va a ser el día que
te voy a apoyar mientras tanto no me
comentas nada al respecto y lo tomé como
un rato y al mismo tiempo me di cuenta
que realmente tenía que validarlo capaz
y si estaba perdiendo mi tiempo y estaba
trabajando sobre creencias y no sobre
realidades decidí juntar a 12 personas
ciegas que probaron este dispositivo
y los resultados fueron increíbles
esto fue lo que le enseñé mi papá
cómo describir este producto en la
palabra
excelente
bajo en la demanda de hábitat porque
ahorita ya las personas ciegas
están buscando bueno estamos buscando
más autonomía y más poder desenvolvernos
por nosotros mismos
en grande
el hecho de de mejorar en cuanto a las
indicaciones como consensuar el más
exactos
pues con esto creo que esto me sentiría
más libre o sé como más
que puedo hacer las cosas sin tanta
necesidad de que alguien
me sentí hasta cierto punto más emerge
del bastón este medio detectaba preciso
en este momento es no solamente lo pedí
a mis papás pero más importante vulneran
el la validación de todas estas personas
en ese mismo rol de prueba yo me topé a
rafa rafa era un atleta paralímpico que
corría 400 y 1500 metros planos
rafa a los 22 años perdió la vista y se
vio forzado por esta discapacidad a
dejar de hacer lo que más le gusta hoy
el depende de su familia y de sus amigos
para realizar cualquier actividad que
necesite y su sueño más grande es
regresar a la pista ese día rafa me dijo
que con esto él iba a poder regresar a
entrenar y en ese momento me di cuenta
que esto dejó de ser un proyecto más y
pasa a ser un proyecto tan grande que
comenzó a ser un emprendimiento un
emprendimiento social que promete
revolucionar como las personas ciegas
exploran el mundo pero si realmente
queríamos sustituir el bastón para
personas ciegas había muchísimo trabajo
por delante en esta ronda de pruebas nos
dieron muchísima retroalimentación para
llegar a donde tenemos que llegar
faltaba mucho para unas semanas de
trabajo haciendo que los sensores
estuvieran en la posición correcta que
la programación sea tan precisa que
detectar a todo tipo de obstáculos desde
cosas en la cabeza escaleras baches
banquetas y bordes personas y paredes
después de meses logramos un proyecto
que hoy puedes sustituir el bastón es un
dispositivo que se pone en el pecho
son especiales que te detectan cualquier
tipo de obstáculo y la vista al usuario
de posibles colisiones por medio de
vibraciones en el cuerpo esto les va a
permitir moverse de una manera mucho más
autónoma de una manera más independiente
y segura que ya no necesitan la ayuda de
nadie más para hacer sus actividades
estás logramos hacer esto y vamos por
muchísimo más es eso del comienzo en
esta ronda de pruebas haciendo este
nuevo proyecto pero ahora necesitamos
hacer demostrar que las personas si
ellas pueden hacer muchísimo más de lo
que pueden hacer hoy para eso nos hemos
estado poniendo nuevos retos como el
reto de víctor hábitos yo me lo topé en
la feria una feria donde no iba a
conocerlo vi que era ciego le conté lo
que estábamos haciendo e inmediatamente
aceptó aprobarse la herramienta que
estamos utilizando y en ese momento
víctor comencé a llorar es la primera
vez que víctor se estaba moviendo en un
evento de más de 15.000 personas como si
nada en un evento donde había muchísima
gente y se estaba moviendo como
cualquier otra persona sin su bastón sin
guía sin nadie que les instó
solamente esta herramienta twitter
comenzó a llorar porque es la primera
vez que sabía que había alguien o algo
en frente de él sin tener sin tener que
tocarlo o pegarle con el bastón fue muy
poderoso para él
y como él nos estamos poniendo más retos
como es el caso de javier la semana
pasada javier de una de sus conferencias
javier es una persona ciega exejecutivo
que hoy juega así que hoy hace ciclismo
juega golf y tenis estando completamente
ciego la semana pasada de javier dio su
conferencia con esta herramienta donde
dejó subasta en un lado y durante todo
el evento esto dando su conferencia y
conviviendo con la gente la vista va
donde está valor y el escenario donde
estaban las paredes y la entrada y la
salida de él
y vamos por mucho más cada vez
demostrando que las personas ellas
pueden tener una independencia muchísimo
más grande y es que las personas que han
hecho grandes cosas no han sido
realistas
la persona que inventó ese método de
comunicación invisible donde te puedes
conectar con cualquier persona del mundo
llamado internet no fue realista la
persona que inventó ese servicio donde
un completo desconocido llega a
recogerte y te lleva en su carro o tu
destino no fue realista en la persona
que hoy está colonizando marte tampoco
fue realista
mi pregunta es de verdad queremos ser
realistas
[Aplausos]